You wanna know where people go wrong in relationships
where they go wrong is
judging their partners everyday choices
Saying, oh that's not how you do that
or oh why are we parking so far
or oh why did you turn into this lane
oh that's not how you do dishes
If you mindlessly do these things
then you're causing friction in your relationship
without even realizing it
or they end up not liking you anymore
or they just become disdainful towards you
when you question somebody's actions
whatever it may be, in everyday life
then feel like they can't do anything right
they feel like they're always in the wrong
nobody wants to be in a relationship
where they feel like everything they do is wrong
if you do these things and you don't even realize it
try to catch yourself before you do it
You want to make your partner feel special
not like they can't do anything right
stop questioning their actions and trust their judgment
At the end of the day
It doesn't matter how you do things
doesn't matter where you're parking
and it doesn't necessarily matter how they do the dishes
they're doing it
that should count right
Instead you should start appreciating that they're putting an effort
or that they're doing these things for you
if you don't want a failed relationship
then start looking at things in a positive light
start appreciating them for doing the dishes to begin with
For doing whatever project to begin with
to be driving you
give them a little bit of credit
if you want a long lasting
loving relationship
huh Frank
I love you, say it
say it back, okay bye